foreign
[Music]
it's been a real privilege this past
year to have been able to do some really
positive uplifting news stories I really
think it's something that people really
need right now and I know for me
personally as a journalist certainly had
a very positive impact on my life
just hope I get through all in the
trailer take the story we did for
example with Newfoundland or Paula Gould
now living in Moncton she saw the sheer
Devastation of what tropical storm Fiona
had created in her hometown a
portabasque and she didn't miss a beat
she immediately put out a call for
donations for people who had truly lost
everything and within just a few days
her garage was filled and she was
hitting the road to Newfoundland with a
trailer full of compassion to get the
water my heart is full I'm just so
overwhelmed and so happy it's just it's
awesome it was absolutely heartwarming
to see and it gave me a sense of hope in
humanity let's face it the last couple
of years have been tough for everyone
really and uh it's been a privilege to
be able to get out into the community
and tell these good news stories and
show people that it's not all bad news
out there there are good things that are
happening in the community and I know
for me personally at least it's really
brought me a sense of gratitude
and sometimes you find it in the most
unexpected places too I never expected
when I came across this group of RC
truck enthusiasts in a park one day and
decided to do a story the depth of the
impact they were having on the community
I saw a side of my son that that we
always long to see and it just popped
out spontaneously so
Steward with the remote welcoming a
young man with autism named Eddie into
their fold turned out to be
life-changing for the family and really
for me too to witness this beautiful
young boy break out of his shell was an
absolute privilege anything that we can
do for awareness
anything that we can do to help
it's all something right
well that certainly was the case for a
Pei family who opened their home to a
cherry farmer fleeing the Ukraine it has
changed our lives and just a very very
meaningful way
and for a Monkton photographer who had
the courage to speak openly about his
prostate cancer hoping to help other men
this is a cancer that men don't want to
deal with don't want to go through
and the smile her teeth I have to admit
I cannot turn down a good animal story
so having had the opportunity over the
last year to do some pretty amazing
animal stories uh well I was just like
sign me up been a rough couple of years
for everybody and animals of all shapes
and sizes are known to have a calming
effect on people a goat yoga was truly
therapeutic and uplifting I mean how can
you not smile when you're trying to do
downward dog surrounded by baby goats
scampering around
which was also true for pugapalooza
where dozens of grumpy-faced pugs ran
around in a fantastically fun frenzy I
think they just have a face that only a
mother could love
and speaking of a good laugh
not one rooster sounds the same as the
other one so I think it's kind of cool
New Brunswick's rooster rescuer well he
left a smile on my face for days well
clearly you have good neighbors my
neighbors are good they even come here
and bring food form or treat
now this next story really touched my
heart the story of Canadian gold medal
swimmer named Jonathan Henry two minutes
is my whole life
I love swimming so much it made a big
splash this year he brought home eight
medals seven of them were gold at the
world Down syndrome swimming
championships in Portugal see I told you
that's why I'm not retiring he said
Jonathan beat the odds reminded us to
never put limits on ourselves it was a
wonderful reminder that these types of
good news stories that have a major
impact on our viewers and on us as
journalists it feels like they're
contributing to the greater good
foreign
[Music]